today marks the 70th anniversary of the  first atomic bomb test in the nevada  desert a u.s air force plane dropped a  one kiloton bomb on frenchman flats  that's northwest of las vegas  at the nevada test site between 1951 and  1992 the u.s military  detonated more than 900 atomic bombs in  nevada though most were underground  and atomic liquor over on fremont street  in downtown vegas  people used to drink and sit on rooftop  to watch those atomic blasts  it is really incredible history it's  part of nevada history  and we want to mention it tonight also  we want to say thanks to those at hanks  we're just informed that the team at  hanks  at green valley ranch is watching  channel 8. so ted and i wanted to say  thank you denise thanks you too